欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,接下来我们讲选品的第二种方法,就是找到对标同行去选品
首先第一个,我们要明确自己的店铺风格和产品类型
第二个就是找到对标同行店铺
第三个就是找到同行店铺里面优秀的产品
第四可以模仿或者直接用它们的热销款式去发产品
前提是不要侵权
那么发完产品之后我们还是一样的逻辑就是
主标题通常是3到10个
那么这里的选款的话
选择款式通常也是3到5款
主标题了之后呢,我们就开始推广, 用新品加速去推广, 然后根据数据去优化
对应的产品标题和产品款式, 也就是在这个步骤我们可以针对产品
去优化标题, 同时呢款式如果是我们选的款式不合理, 或者是说转化太低,
那么我们也可以重新选款式, 把整个链接的主图和详情页都换成新的款式, 把整个链接的主图和详情页都换成新的款式, 就按这个实录去推广就可以了, 那么具体怎么样去选, 我们来看一下, 比如说你的店铺是主要做卫衣的,
而且这些风格已经很明确了, 那么你就要去找到对标同行的店铺, 首先怎么找呢?第一个, 我们可以通过榜单搜索, 比如说我们在这里, 首页是吧, 我们找到对应的榜单, 进入榜单之后, 我们就去看, 就按照这种顺序去看一次性点开, 前10名的所有的店铺去看, 点开之后我们要进入他的店铺,
一定要进入他的店铺, 进入店铺之后, 你要去看他的整理风格, 衣服的风格, 以及他的产品的那个内幕, 跟你的是不是极为相似的, 或者是所做的品类是不是跟你很相似, 如果相似的话, 那点进产品里面, 这里在所有产品这里搜索, 按一下空格键, 点击搜索, 搜索出来之后, 我们按照, 综合, 或者是订单, 降序来排行,
去找到这些款式
你就可以去挖掘很多款式了
你通过多个店铺去挖掘
那么你最后面就得到很多种类型的款式了
这样去看
好像这个都是他们家的
你找一些不同类型的店铺
理解吧
就是不要都是一个店铺
你要去把这些打开
去找到对应的店铺点击进店
进店
这样是不是
是不是出现这个店铺跟这个店铺
这个店铺跟这个店铺
他们是
选择不一样的店铺
选择了店铺之后就按照那个方法直接去看他的产品你看这些是不是你主营的
点开空格
搜索把这些款式整理出来
结合多个店铺整理出来
以后
你就去对标他们店铺把他们的链接
拿下来每周去看
他有哪些产品推广的效果非常好
或者是说最近
涨幅非常
好的, 直接你就参考他这种款式去打造就可以了
标题跟那些方面你不用去完全照盘, 一定不要照盘, 你只需要参考他的款式
你知道这个产品的这个款式很好, 你就用其他的关键词去推广他就可以了
这是第一种方法就是去找到热销的产品, 第二个方法呢在首页去搜索
对应的核心的品类的产品池, 比如说你去搜索位于这个核心品类, 去看下面自然排名的产品, 就是没有广告位的, 从自然排名开始去一个个点击, 点击大概五到十个就可以了, 进入他们店铺, 还是跟刚才那个方式一样, 进入他们店铺, 一个个进入他们店铺, 找到相似的款式, 再去看, 再多个店进行对比, 确定你要选择的,
哪些款式就可以了, 这些什么主标题啊, 开始推广啊, 我们前面和直动车板块全部都已经讲过了, 你就选好了款, 你就按照标准的方法去主标题和具体的方法去推广就可以了, 这个呢也是比较简单的, 主要就是找对标同行这个店铺上面去挖掘就可以了, 还有另一种方式呢, 我们可以在这个, 比如说
比如说我们在首页主页这里可以直接点制造商这边
制造商的话你可以就看前面这些访单的这些跟你极为相似的店铺去参考他们的款式就可以了
另外如果是3月9月大处的时候是不是会有那些什么户户流啊
那些也可以从那里面去选一些店铺的去参考
这些方式都很多, 主要是找到热销的店铺, 就可以了, 你把这些店铺整理到一个, 一下表格里面, 以后就, 经常去参考对标他们, 最近更新什么, 最近在推哪些款式, 他们这些款式的, 寻盘量啊, 订单量啊, 怎么样, 好评等等, 通过这些维度去, 对标他们, 我们, 针对自己店铺里面去, 推广这类产品就可以了,
这样能够大大缩减我们推广浪费的预算
这些都是直接用别人已经成功的产品去推广
那么你拿到的询盘是非常容易的,而且是非常快的
那么这个就是我们所说的第二种方法
对标优秀同行选品
这个方法可以每周都去看,每周都去用
好了,这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见